Oh everybody how's everybody doing I
hope you're doing fine the virus didn't
catch you first I want to say that we
postpone the Lusaka conference that we
were supposed to have in April for some
reason Lusaka is the only country in the
world that locked its borders won't let
people out or in I don't know what's
going on over there so we got a week to
the some young authorities opened their
borders again we don't know when that
will happen okay so yeah we postponed
the conference and we're gonna have to
reschedule it we don't know yet when
what's gonna happen at all in the world
okay I just want to remind also people
everybody there that we have the rope
hypothesis the book it's up there for
you to download a trope hypothesis calm
okay you can go into books and you will
find a PDF file that you can download it
for free it put you up to this day that
brings you up to speed on what this site
is about okay and I also want to mention
that anyone who wishes to who has the
second language and wants to translate
the book to his second language please
contact us at toca caca at hotmail.com
and we'll send you a file that you can
work with to translate it into your
native language anyways what am I going
to talk about today well I want to talk
a little bit about this issue of the
virus that's going on in the world why
because I have an extinction theory for
those of you who are not aware I've been
talking about it for the last twenty
years and I think this virus may have
something to do with that extinction
theory maybe I don't know that's what
I'm going to try to find out myself but
the issue is that I'm going to talk
about the extinction theory and
how it relates perhaps to the virus or
how the virus might trigger what I
proposed twenty years ago and if I get
half time I'm gonna deal with some of
the comments regarding wave theory that
we dealt with a couple couple sessions
ago anyways uh one of the problems that
I've got is people don't seem to
understand what the theory is about and
they're putting words in my mouth or
misunderstanding the theory
misrepresenting it and therefore this
forces me to clarify the theory for I
guess the tenth time maybe someone will
listen out there and and figure out what
the theory is about the theory is about
extinction but the mechanism no one
seems to have grasped it or very few
people seem to grasp it and I got a one
of a person who was aware of the theory
sent a an article and the articles about
this fellow in England who wrote a book
published I think now in March and he
talks about food yeah yeah that's right
down my alley because it's a food theory
and this guy talks about the food
situation in England okay and in the UK
and he goes over some of the problems
that the UK has with food or with food
policy and this fellow put this article
there like saying Jesus you know if if
this guy's right then maybe bills theory
might might be true and the issue is
that what this guy says this author has
absolutely nothing to do with my theory
and so someone so much got it wrong and
I want to clarify that the theory has
nothing to do with what you'll hear from
these people from from this author okay
so let me show you the author first okay
and here it is this fellow
Tim lang and he says he says we have
massive
a massively fragile just-in-time supply
chain which could easily easily collapse
okay and he says that in Britain the
agricultural sector produces around 50%
of the food that we actually eat and
he's complaining that essentially the UK
is relying on imports too much of its
food source comes from abroad and that
just eight companies controlled the
ninety percent of the food supply okay
and so that's that's essentially his
argument and I just want to clarify that
none of this has anything to do with my
theory okay none of what this person
just said there has anything to do with
the theory now it has to do with England
and its ability to overcome a some kind
of catastrophe out there where it
somehow is isolated from all these
supplies that come from abroad that's a
separate issue but that's not what the
theory my theory says okay so I want to
make sure that's understood okay what I
do like about them let me put this up
again is the last statement a statement
that he made in there which is this one
he says we have a we have a default
position of assuming someone else will
feed us oh I love that one I love that
one because he wasn't aware of what he
said you know that statement someone
else will feed us applies to every
person on earth essentially maybe
there's some hunter-gatherers he feeds
himself but every one of us depends on
someone else to feed us see that wasn't
the case with basil hunter-gatherers of
the upper Palaeolithic and it certainly
is not the same for you know for the few
hundred gatherers that are out there
that maybe hunt some animal and feed off
of that you know everybody else in the
world essentially depends on someone
else feeding them and we're not aware of
that so you think
that you just go to a store and get
something you're not even conscious of
this and it turns out yeah we depend on
other people to feed us keep that in
mind okay we depend on others to feed us
and without feeding we're dead that
sounds like extinction at least for the
individual okay and out of that article
it referenced another article as well
and this article said again analyzes the
food situation again in England or in
the UK and again talks about says we now
produce 60% but because of exports only
about 50% of the food we eat is actually
produced here that's in in the UK right
and this means we are now to risk from
global shocks including exceptional
weather and what are the next disease
which is what we're having today or
disturbances in commodity markets etc so
yeah why doesn't any of that have to do
with a theory might you my theory says
one thing that you got to get clear
right up front if you don't understand
that there's no reason in pursuing you
in going any further with questions or
comments or beliefs or whatever you have
to understand the bottom line the bottom
line is money will disappear money will
be no more that's the theory now if you
find anyone on planet earth today
present today or ever in the history of
life on Earth that said money will
disappear I'll buy you a beer okay there
there is no such theory out there you
can look in the Wikipedia you can look
in the letters in blogs or whatever
experts from the universities you will
not find a single person saying that
money will disappear money will be no
more okay I want to get that straight
because that goes into one ear and come
out the other and people just keep
blabbing about stuff that I haven't said
I said money
disappear I don't know how difficult
that can be for people to understand
money will disappear now you might say
well I believe that money will disappear
that's what 99.99 percent of humanity
says I don't care I want you to
understand that that's the theory the
theory that I'm proposing money will
disappear okay so whether you believe in
it or you might say well how will it
disappear again
right now it's irrelevant right now we
can't even get you to understand the
prayer money will disappear and that's
the theory the theory says money will
disappear and so that's the first thing
you need to get clear unless you
understand that you will not understand
anything else because you'll say a lot
of people say well yeah bills right you
know the climate is changing and that's
gonna affect our food production or we
don't have enough land on planet earth
to feed you know eight billion people or
or you know we're running out of water
or maybe out of fuel to to power all
these things they come up with a bunch
of stuff that has nothing to do with my
theory the theory is money will
disappear your money will be no more
okay I hope that's clear
and yeah if you look at the paper which
I got there in the in the description
there's two papers there you look at the
one that says we are the last generation
of humans on earth it'll give you an
idea of just a very vague idea you know
a very broad idea of what what I'm
referring to I'm saying that money will
be no more okay so you know when you
when you cut the chain of money see
right now we have a chain and it's all
connected that chain is money that
connects all aspects of our global
economy the producer of food right
the agriculturist he or the company the
corporation sells to a transportation
company or even might even be the
transportation company the way that
they're monopolizing every aspect of
Agriculture today so goes to the
producer the guy who manufactures food
or pack
or you know processes it in some way
from there it goes again through
transportation to the stores okay and
from the stores it goes to the consumer
and the consumers the guy who works at
the agricultural corporation you know
some of them at least right and so it
goes all around all that's connected by
a chain called money it only works
because of money the whole chain the
whole cycle you cut the chain you get
rid of money and nothing new works
anymore ok that's the theory the theory
says if money disappears for whatever
reason God comes in there just waves his
magic wand there's no more money nobody
believes in money and anymore nobody
accepts money anymore ok are you
following me if money disappears
completely for whatever reason the
double put his tail in there I don't
care what is if money disappears right
that whole cycle disintegrates
completely now you have what I call the
chain of faith we have to pray for our
food because someone else feeds us we
depend on someone else to feed us ok
right now the your culture will come if
money collapses right
nony disappears corporation that
produces the food that plant the
agricultural corporation will not accept
money right from the transportation or
the manufacturing company ok because
money is no more right they don't accept
money anymore and the corporation that
manufactures or processes food won't
accept money from the supermarket's
supermarkets won't accept money from the
consumer and the consumer won't accept
salary from the corporation the whole
cycle breaks down if we can get rid of
money so if God comes here you know
after so many thousands of years seven
thousand years I think it was and wage
this magic wand and somehow you know
instead of making it rain for forty days
and forty nights just gets rid of money
we're done
you know the whole system breaks
down and without money we can't get any
food without food we all die that's a
biological fact okay so that's the
theory the theory is money disappears
okay if you stray from there and say
well the climate and peak oil and all
these other effects nothing to do with
it absolutely nothing to do with it at
all hey money will disappear that's the
thing you need to get that part straight
in there okay I talked about the other
day about some of the macro processes
that we cannot avoid
okay these are macro processes that were
predictable in retrospect which we could
not have avoided and we cannot avoid
even now if we go forward okay and let's
even get it here I don't know why it
doesn't show up ah what is going on here
somehow I can't get one of these things
to show up I see it but I know that
you're not seeing it I'm not sure what
happened here see if I can get another
one of these up there oh yeah that one
shows up I'm not sure what happened here
okay
anyways there's some macro processes
I'll just have to read it to you because
I don't know why I can't I can't get you
to see it that is magic
anyways I'll just read them out to you
one is transition from country to the
city that's been going on for some time
now okay
across the world across the planet
people are moving from the country to
the city from the farmlands to the
metropolitan areas they're looking for
work the land is being bought out by
agricultural corporations and now they
have these economies of scale where they
process food on a grand scale and they
get rid of the little farmer that's a
process that's going on across the
planet every country in the under planet
is doing that essentially so we're
moving from agricultural manufacturing
to services you know we there was a
process we started in the Neolithic and
where we invented or discovered
agriculture and from there we moved on
to manufacturing eventually we started
trading and from there we became more
and more efficient at manufacturing and
eventually moved people out of
manufacturing and into services and one
of the things you know some people say
well you know services it's good means
that we have very low unemployment
thanks to the fact we have all these
people working here and there and
everywhere and what they miss is that
services is for the most part
unemployment okay there is services as
an unemployment category essentially you
look at finance 20% of the US economy at
least is financed including banking and
insurance and so on
and if you credit you know and if you
look at if that you know it's all
promises finances so for the most part
is is promises it's a different kind of
service than a person who mows your lawn
or cut your hair you know you have an
immediate benefit services of the
financial kind is futuristic you know if
you don't use insurance and you pay for
it maybe you never use insurance in your
life and then you die you know you pay
for nothing you pay for a promise and so
you got to think about that a lot of
that is is masked unemployment okay
someone said oh we have more people
working today yeah but they're working
in the service industry and services is
for the most part unemployment so and if
we add to that the fact that people are
making lower wages today real wages
that's also a way of masking
unemployment so unemployment is is a
weirdworld word okay
it's it's got many categories in fact
there's I think six types of
unemployment that the government always
Ponder's and analyzes then we have the
other issue the demographic pyramid
overturning that's that was unavoidable
the species our species is growing older
and older and older we are in old
species people say well we've been
around for only two hundred thousand
years yeah Mother Nature doesn't count
the age of a species by the number of
rotations of the earth around the Sun
mother nature counts it by whether we
have lost our genetic diversity which
humans have and by whether the majority
of the population is over the hill
that's that's when your species is old
okay and that's where we are today and
that's why you know our birth rates have
gone down and are heading towards zero
population growth in other words where
we're not producing kids anymore partly
be in great measure because we moved to
the cities and you can't have kids in
the cities so it's all intertwined
so we and we could not have avoided this
and if you look at just a piece of bread
that you put on the table leave it for a
month or so turn it until it turns green
the bacteria will multiply first and
then at some point they'll start stop
reproducing miracle
it's called density dependent birth
rates that's what humans are subjected
to today density dependent birth rates
we do not produce kids because we have
too much density into little economics
and we're all crowded in cities that's
why you stopped having kids okay anyways
employment bottlenecks unavoidable also
the old stay in their jobs and young
can't get in there okay innovation
efficiency it was predictable that we
would have put new inventions primarily
innovations in the workforce apply
computers etc to make things more
efficient and what that does is you know
weed out the worker
we don't need workers anymore gang or
ever fewer and fewer of them
entitlements unavoidable social security
welfare unemployment health insurance
all those entitlements you know the
government has to pay for those and why
what does that do governments incur debt
as a result of that okay it's
unavoidable
so government runs up the tab because
they have to pay for these entitlement
which are included in the law okay
you're entitled to certain benefits and
the government has to pay for that and
that's paid for from the workers that
work they take a little bit out of their
paycheck from there they pay the people
who don't work or who need health or
whatever retirement currency devaluation
okay
what we have is government creating
money okay when government creates money
it automatically is lowering your salary
unless there is increase in your salary
proportionate to the money created by
the government you just lost some money
and real wages have been falling in fact
here I have a little chart hopefully
this one shows up okay and you can see
what's happened to to the real wages of
workers in the last wet 40 50 60 years
okay since 1948 okay you can see that we
were pretty much doing at least the US
right this is for the US but it gives
you an idea it was a predict
productivity and already compensation
were pretty much hand to hand all the
way until 73 and then he started
separating now we have a lot of
productivity but that doesn't show up in
your paycheck okay and so workers are
making less and less real wages that's
that's what it comes down to okay okay
and again let me look at the one final
couple more here the stock market
volatility the fact that we have all
these bubbles we had a housing bubble in
2008 we have a derivatives bubble coming
up maybe you know a lot of casino
playing by the banks okay that could pop
any moment and then we have finally the
fact that all food is being concentrated
by a few corporations which is what this
English guy was saying you know that you
have very few cultural corporations or
food corporations because they do the
transportation as well processing some
of them and what they do is they have
they have very few corporations doing
the whole work and that puts our lives
in in the hands of very few corporations
that's that's what you got to think
about so all these were unavoidable
macro processes and they were
predictable okay and I think all that
points to the fact that we are going to
hit a brick wall at some point with the
economy we cannot continue growing
forever especially population doesn't
grow which means demand doesn't grow
and I know a lot of people out there say
you're crazy uh well that's that's my
take on it I'm saying that you cannot
replace quantity with quality you cannot
say well we make new products and people
want to have new products in blah blah
blah I don't buy on any of that nonsense
no no it's it's a volume issue uh if you
want the economy world economy to grow
very simple you have one trillion
Martians put orders to earth for all
kinds of products and you'll see us
booming like you've never seen it before
you'll see even factory is running at
full speed hiring workers just to
produce for the one trillion Martians so
yeah numbers are important okay volume
is important and that happened in the
19th century when population was
expanding blowing up and people are
demanding products and new inventions
were coming online so it was a very
dynamic era that's not the error we have
today at all okay so we have a different
situation today anyways if you go back
in time you the question is whether any
of this is going to go like in by Mauro
Republic Germany I put some clips here
just so that you can see this is what
happened to the to the mark
okay the marks in circulation versus
prices you can see what happened in
1920s these are the curves okay and what
happened was that the money devaluated
so much that it became worthless
essentially people were using marks to
Deutsche marks right to heat their
stoves because it was cheaper than
buying coal I guess okay and my
grandmother was German and she was there
in 1923 she left Germany in that year
and and she said it was incredible you
had to take like a million marks or
whatever to buy a piece of bread it was
just unbelievable
yeah here's a cartoon that pretty much
puts it in perspective again prices out
of control again and so you can see the
person taking tons of bills just to buy
who knows a boat loaf of bread or
whatever apples and it just kept growing
here these guys are putting all kinds of
bills in there yeah just to buy
something and the question is whether
this is going to happen again you know
and I asked the some Germans here
Germany yeah well they're anything like
this could ever happen again in Germany
they just take their heads and and laugh
at me they said what do you think this
is gonna happen again are you crazy or
what and now we have lockdowns Germany
so you tell me if if anything can happen
and I'll tell you yeah anything can
happen that's that's the best way to see
it so what happens when when the economy
reaches problems like we have today
where you have a virus that locked us
all in here in Hesse in Ramat the state
has not does not have a lockdown it just
has a voluntary you know keep your
distance policy okay but in the south
and Babar yeah and other states their
limit bordering with Switzerland and
France they're in lockdown
you know they've got the Gestapo on and
yes s all of them should stuff up on the
streets
okay guarding you know your your health
okay and so this is what would happen
you know first day you have when you
have a crash of some kind you have
people first marching in the streets
protesting the cost of living the first
march through Main Street then they
march all the way to the Capitol or
these legislature or the Congress or
whatever of their city or their country
you know it starts peaceful okay and
then it gets less and less peaceful for
some reason okay we get to pitchfork day
okay that's that's when the workers of
the world unite and they start
the police a little more determined
second time you know and now there's no
longer a peaceful march now they come in
and they demand certain things and yeah
you have the crowds meeting up with a
police okay and you might say well that
doesn't happen anymore
special inna advance country like
germany can't imagine happening here you
i it states china under communism
maybe russia i don't know will it happen
in these countries these countries that
are so overly controllable people really
go out there well it depends on how
desperate they are i mean if you're
starving and somehow food rations are
not enough or they are the food doesn't
get to you you know you're the so-called
state of siege oh yeah anything can
happen and one of the things can happen
is what you just saw and this is what
happened in germany right after the war
you had all kinds of people of you know
rioting and complaining and protesting
and whatever they you have millions of
people's in the street of people in the
streets just uh demanding their their
share of the wealth and so yeah there
are marches and those marches can become
violent and when you have that kind of
thing yeah it's a different kind of
world that then the one you're used to a
lot of people today are not aware that
that this even happened a lot of people
are saying well it'll never happen again
those who are aware and so the question
is you know is this gonna happen again
doesn't have any chance whatsoever in
your mind yeah here's a one of the
things you which is iconic for the 1920s
okay these are the soup kitchens will
this ever happen again where you have
you know all these laid off workers
welfare people retirees and etc and he
come in for just a plate of soup okay
and yeah and the date heartily and the
government has to pay for this or or
you know it's done through donations of
whatever you got a lineup on the streets
just you eat a plate of food do you
think this will ever happen again
officially no an advanced nation or is
this beyond reason thinking that this
will never happen again
you got to think about all these things
because right now you yeah in many
places right now there's lockdowns
cities countries there's lockdowns and
they say two weeks maybe a month maybe a
month and a half
fine and it's very likely that we'll get
back to normal after that whatever
normal is okay but you got to keep in
mind that normal is no longer normal
first of all this is not normal this is
totally unprecedented and second even
even when it blows over
the virus and everybody's allowed to get
out of their houses because the danger
is now no longer that dire okay will the
economy be back to normal I mean you
know you have lots of unemployed people
and can you get them back to their jobs
will there be jobs to hire these people
back yeah when you have millions of
workers out into the streets
well you're approaching more a soup
kitchen and riot type scenario than you
are a normality so the problem is not
the virus the problem is the economy
okay that's that's what I think you
should keep in mind and here's a what
happened in Argentina you know in 2001
they broke into stores crowbars whatever
and they stole everything they could
food from the shelves did they pay for
all that stuff I don't think so okay
they just broke in there okay and stole
whatever they could okay a lot of them
opportunists you know maybe there was no
need but that's what people will do when
there's riots when there's a loosening
of of the conditions in the in the
country if people are having trouble
getting to the end of the month
okay they'll go in there in the in rob a
store and you know there was this
Chinese guy I knew he had a store and he
said he couldn't believe that neighbors
that that would say hi every morning to
him would come in there and steal from
his store right in front of his eyes to
steal whatever they could and run out
and he these were people he knew in his
in his zone so yeah yeah I mean
sometimes you can't believe how people
will change overnight because of
necessity you can say that they're just
opportunities opportunists but there is
an element of necessity that drives
people to do these things and if there
is lawlessness and maybe the cops are
not around or maybe the cops even help
you like in the Russian Revolution where
the cops went in there and they didn't
worry about security they went in there
to get their bag of flour yeah and then
you got a problem you got a problem in
the country and yeah a lot of people
might say well Bill see we had all these
probably headed from in Germany another
one in Russia and we always overcame it
yeah but see the this is the issue the
issue is now we're talking global see
when when Russia had a problem Germany
had a problem there were other countries
that weren't doing is bad and you know
have countries that sell to other
countries to get them out of the mess
for a little while you know in the
United States and England were helping
Russia against Germany during the war
there were other countries you know
helping Germany and so on you know after
the war and so on so so as long as one
country can help another country no
problem but would it the whole world is
a country all connected by ships and
airplanes which deliver goods and
services etc and suddenly that system
breaks down well now you have the whole
world who's going to help us the
Martians it's a closed system then okay
what you had in the 1920s 1930s and
1940s was not a closed system you had
one
system that had problems and another one
help them out emergency help or whatever
you had the Marshall Plan also you know
after the war you had that because
someone was rich and someone was poor
someone was in need the other one had
what this guy needed so they reached an
agreement but what if what if the entire
planet is is a country which is more or
less a situation here where the whole
world depends on the whole world were
the dollar for example is what people
use in the world and suddenly that
dollar collapses now you got a problem
because now you you need the Martians to
come in and help you help bail you out
and people don't always understand that
the situation today is very different
than what we had before during the war
and even before the war during the
Depression era okay and so what happens
when when things get real bad in your
Township in your ghetto you might run
out of supplies maybe there's not enough
water maybe electricity is shut down or
something
and so the army or the National Guard or
some some government military force
comes in and says okay folks why don't
you get into the trains okay we're gonna
take you for a ride okay so they put
people on the trains and they start
taking you to maybe a concentration camp
where they say well we can provide you
there with food water electricity
whatever you need
would you get on the train do you think
that's a good decision I mean you either
stay behind and starve or whatever you
have nothing to drink or you go with the
National Guard that promises to feed you
in whatever until things get better it's
always until things get better right so
it's it's your choice you stay behind or
already go yeah and you can go on trains
you can also go on trucks that's the way
they did it again in those days
during before in after the war right
after the war and you can see people
loading onto the trucks what if they
come with a military trucks and say you
want to get on or even worse they say
you must get on board what would you do
would you get on board that truck or
would you rather start behind and take
your chances at your home or would you
rather go into the concentration camp
okay and see if you survive in there
better than outside can this ever happen
again
anything similar to that where shortages
become so dire that you have no other
choice but either to get on the truck or
weather even worse maybe they force you
up to the truck okay you gotta think
about these things if you think that any
of this might happen again
and yeah at the camps you have no
problem you have these guards they'll
put you straight though make you stand
up straight and salute okay you have
your own medical services at your home
yeah this is what you might be seeing
you have your own bunk bed hey bunk man
you have your soup kitchen all in one
all in the same place okay so yeah you
have guaranteed labor the whole works
you do it why not why not get onto that
truck right and yeah here's the outwits
the camp okay that gives you an idea
what it looked like and you might be put
into some camp like that with thousands
of people okay but you get on that truck
would you get on that train or would you
stay behind is the question do you think
this will ever happen again is there any
chance whatsoever in your mind that this
could happen again and you can imagine
that just think about what you're
looking at there if money is no more if
right bigger but if buddy is no more
well all you have is is food
is food and you need to get on the truck
unless you have your own store somehow
you know or for I don't know how many
years such your choice you either get on
the truck or you don't
and the other possibility is that they
force you out to the truck could happen
right I mean we don't know which one
would happen in and if you get on the
truck or whether you stay behind
either way money is no more you got to
think about that those people that went
on the truck they had no more money now
they depended on someone else to feed
them and it's not like you know you're
in a concentration camp you don't go in
there with money and say okay I'm gonna
buy something because money has no value
at that moment in time okay so think
about that you know at that point money
has no value and if you stay behind for
sure money has no value so the question
is how can we reach that point is it
possible to reach that point that's
that's the issue well let's see if we're
anywhere close to that here we have
Goldman Sachs okay and this is what they
say regarding the coronavirus they say
that second quarter coming up now right
85% of sports and entertainment loss
decline seventy five percent decline in
transportation 65 percent in hotel
restaurant which already has suffered
quite a bit and they revised their six
percent drop to twenty four percent drop
unprecedented and maybe they're a little
pessimistic you might say okay could be
here's the several banks including
Goldman Sachs these are their
predictions or their proposals they say
that Goldman Sachs you get the twenty
four percent their decline credits which
says it's twelve percent half of that
UBS Switzerland Bank - nine point five
Barclays seven and so on down the line
you can see that they have very
different numbers and that should give
you an idea that these people have no
idea whatsoever what's coming because
they have such different numbers
and the interesting thing is that a
quarter three and quarter four it's all
pluses so they say it's only going to
last one quarter and then we're back to
normal
okay or or more or less normal we're
gonna start growing again and you can
see the percentages are all different
for all these big corporations and so
the question is are these people
guessing I mean they're guessing as much
as I am guessing okay is are there
astrologers any better than me and I
recognize I'm a lousy astrologer okay
I don't confuse science with astrology
and these people do astrology they make
all these predictions they don't know if
this is the last fall maybe just keep
falling and falling and falling okay and
I discussed that to some degree the
other day and here's a one company
Barron's some of you have heard it of
them okay and there they had their like
ten of their experts give an idea what
you should buy and these people are
buying some people are buying toilet
paper these people buy stocks if it
falls falling out about far enough
they'll buy it they think it's a good
deal because they buy and then they wait
for third quarter and come back up and
they make they make a killing and that's
their hope okay the question is where
the third quarter is going to go up or
you go further down and you might say
well bill it's got to go up because we
all go but back to work know there are a
lot of companies that are gonna go
bankrupt and I'm not sure how much of
that labor force is going to be hired
back again you know you're gonna have a
loss of anywhere according to mr. Trump
in fact I'll pull it up here in a second
he says or his administration says that
they think right they they believe
there's gonna be like 20% unemployment
right dutiful coronavirus now just to
give you an idea the 1929 stock market
crash produced in the 30s a 22 percent
unemployment rate and so here they're
talking about Depression era type
situation okay and the question is
whether it's just gonna last one quarter
or it's going to go beyond because you
got to think about something
once people who lose their jobs in
certain types of industries you know
those jobs are not created back again so
swiftly because there's not enough
demand for those services or goods and
services
maybe goods but not services services is
a luxury economy you know you get you
pay the guy to mow your lawn now you
gotta mow it yourself and so that guy
lost his income and so on you know so
you get a lot of this stuff that you got
to think about whether it's really gonna
pick up and it might I'm not saying it
doesn't but keep that in mind to two to
three million people that lose their
jobs that's a big hit on the economy and
when they lose their jobs they don't get
them back overnight
takes a while and the question is
whether in the meantime instead of going
up it goes down further down you have
more unemployment because now you don't
have enough demand and that's why you
need the one trillion dollar stimulus
give money to people so that they can go
out and spend it and stimulate the
economy again okay it's an artificial
trick that keeps us alive you know keeps
us going and I talked about the chain
reaction the other day this is what I
think happens in general okay you have
the coronavirus strike people and what
happens is governments and so on
overreact perhaps and because of that
you created this panic and what happens
now corporations lose their revenue and
workers lose their jobs and consumers
stop buying and then the cycle repeats
itself again starting at corporations
lose their revenue and the only thing
government can do is just give money to
all these people and say okay we're
going to give you money to keep you
going that's a and that's about as much
as they can do that's it okay whether
that's gonna work
in the long run it's up to you to figure
out you know whether that's the case
yeah I made a little illustration of
what happens when more and more workers
lose their job
and have to maintain the few workers
that remain have to maintain an
ever-growing population of unemployed of
couch potatoes okay and here you see the
little trick how it goes it's a little
uh it was straights what's happening
okay or what could happen what you have
is more and more people losing their
jobs okay which is what's happening
right now
and more couch potatoes on the right
okay and you can't have this go on
forever at some point you got to hire
people back up because otherwise the
entire economy collapses and I'm saying
that this process eventually isn't is
unavoidable because an economy can't
grow forever and it can't grow forever
in great measure because we're not
producing consumers we're not producing
children okay so you know we have a
Ponzi scheme that's what our economy is
like essentially that's what it boils
down to you have to have more people or
like if you're a car company you you
make your calculations that next year
you're gonna sell more cars why are you
gonna sell more cars well because people
that you have more people and those
people have money and if you don't have
more people and the people who remain
have less money less disposable income
you're not gonna sell more cars you're
gonna have to lay people off from the
assembly line and so on down the line
and so and then now you have more work
more unemployed people clinging on to
the system and that's what that will
give so so this is what I think is gonna
happen I think it's gonna be a total
economic collapse eventually given
enough time I'm sorry I don't have any
good news but that's my take that's what
I think is gonna happen and why do I
think it's gonna happen also if you put
in the context of mass extinctions I'm
saying all mass extinctions happen in
the same way they happened when the
economy collapsed the economy collapsed
on the dinosaurs okay their economy
all animals have an economy and their
economy is food that's it
economy of an animal's food that's all
that an animal has to worry about in the
wild right has to worry about every day
day in day out
where's he gonna get his food okay
Presley the carnivores you know the cows
have it easy in general you know they
find it on the ground when there is
unless there's dry season you know then
they die as well but cows can eat their
grass and then someone eats the cow
that's how it works and when the bottom
rung collapses the primary production
collapses the whole system collapses and
that's what would happen to us if we
lose if money disappears if money
disappears for sure there's no one to
toil the land no corporation that has
any incentive to put seeds on the ground
okay and when that happens we're all in
trouble because as long as we have money
no problem but when money disappears now
we have a real problem now no one goes
in there in plants no one distributes
and the cities just starve to death and
that's what I think is gonna happen just
like it happened to the dinosaurs when
their food sources disappeared they died
nope no asteroid no volcanoes no
supernovas for sure for sure none of
those can explain selectivity especially
chronological selectivity okay okay I'm
gonna get a little time so let me see if
we can work on some of the comments that
were made regarding the wave nature of
light that we discussed the other day if
that's the amplitude decays the speed of
light and this was one of the comments
that was made says hey dude you are
wrong as usual okay you can produce
staining way with a free and just look
at such as such gave me a reference
right there is a both example with free
and with a fixed end okay so what did he
point to well he pointed to this okay
this is my answer first the only reason
you can probe because this is what I had
said he just responded to this I said
the only reason you can produce a
standing wave it's because it's got to
be tied at both ends okay okay I said
tie to both ends but the issue was that
you know you if you don't hold the
so-called wave whatever is the thing
that's waving and I showed it with my my
rope okay if I don't hold it at one end
you know I can't create the standing
wave okay that's what I was saying and
he said well here we have a wave that is
not held at both ends and I had to see
that I see what is he referring to okay
and what he showed you or what he
pointed to was this okay
J he says this wave so you can see it
there he says hey yeah it's not held at
the other end
yeah but he's cheating and he doesn't
realize that he's got a bar metal bar
there underneath that's holding the
whole thing up if we take that bottom
part out can he can he do that same
little trick if we don't have that
supporting rod okay so this guy really
has some kind of little problem in his
head if he thinks that you can do a
standing wave without holding the other
end or I got it I guess add that
something holding the whole wave up I
mean what is he saying is there a rod
connecting every atom in the universe
and the wave moves are over the rod is
that what he's saying turns out that
that wave machine was done that's like a
second generation here was the first
generation this was done by the British
okay and it's the Royal Institution who
produced this wave machine okay and they
produced it in 2008 and here's their
machine and one of the first things they
say there as you can see is that then
the Machine sits on horizontal bars
which are threaded together with wires
so it has a something to hold it up and
here's the here's the wave okay you can
see it there
and generated and you know again you can
see that the wave comes back over itself
why because it's it's being held by a
rod so there is no such thing as a
standing wave that doesn't have a rod
underneath it or or it's tied at the
other end one of the two has to happen
you can you can't have a wave without
without some kind of support okay and
then here's the reflection version of
there's of this Vinny comb machine a
wave machine you can see how it is it's
and and remember the wave is on the
edges by the way okay so it's an optical
illusion in a way right but yeah you
have to have some kind of rod you can't
you can't do away without either touch
holding the other ends or putting a rod
underneath and if you put the rod well
you gotta explain what that rod is in
terms of the transverse wave that people
say that light is so are they saying as
this fall saying that the transverse
wave is held up by a rod so yeah he
hasn't realized that he didn't come
through in his head okay another comment
here said said how the hell a field can
be a concept talking primarily about a
magnetic field if a field has to has two
types of shapes lines and circles it is
not a concept than it is not an object
that's physics want to say a field is a
region in space whatever that means okay
which is holding potential to do work
look at this figure it looks like a
concept if it is formed in front of your
eyes well again a big problem here as
people do not define their terms and
they think they can get away without
defining terms so we try to address this
by starting at the beginning we define
what an object is that way we can use
the word consistently what is an object
object is that which has shape okay it's
got to be a standalone object
you should it should be the only object
in the universe that's how we should
visualize objects okay and if you go
into at least the Wikipedia here you get
a definition of what what a field is
okay says field is a physical quantity
that has a value for each point in space
so field is a quantity right or as in
mathematics that is a set right then
you're talking about an abstraction
you're not talking about a physical
object so you know if this fella says oh
I'm offended that you said that a field
is not an object yeah it's a concept
field discontent it's just a bunch of
numbers at each point in space that's
all it is it's a region of numbers not a
region of things and people don't
understand that they've used the word
field for so many centuries now that
aurelion for two centuries that they do
not realize they're dealing with a
concept okay and here let's show that
it's a concept okay an object is a
standalone object like that blob that
you see there the white one and in the
second one you see an angel okay and
with a halo but it's not the halo is not
a standalone object a halo but do we
have if it's standalone it's just a ring
not a halo halo requires an angel and
likewise the magnet the field requires a
magnet without the magnet you don't have
a standalone field you you cannot have a
standalone field alone in the universe
you need to have something someplace
where that fuel has origin
okay people don't always understand that
you can't have a field without a magnet
okay and so let's see if I can get this
other one here give me a second here
here's a magnet under water you can see
it's pulling each iron filing
individually one at a time so you gotta
identify what makes up the field there's
something that's making up the so-called
field field it's just the region where
all those magnets are moving well where
all those are
these are moving there is no standalone
object called fields field is not only
not a standalone object but it's made of
something that is in motion a field is a
dynamic concept yeah that's what it is
and people again because they don't
define their terms they don't know what
they're talking about and so just in
case we bring a little authority to
Baroness from mr. Faraday and mr.
Maxwell and they they said that you know
field is made of something you know
Maxwell said you know it's uh in that
space there's matter in motion okay and
Faraday said here it comes up I cannot
conceive curved lines of force without
conditions of a physical existence they
knew that lines of force and that that
so-called field was mediated by
something that was material physical
there was an exotic kind of material or
matter or whatever but they couldn't
figure that out and so they said well
well it's matter in motion what it is I
don't know but it's matter in motion so
field is matter in motion matter in
motion is a concept it's not a
standalone object okay so from from
every point of view from any point of
view a field is not a physical object
standalone physical objects not
independent it's something in motion
it's something that's made of something
that is in motion from all those points
of your field is not an object and I
know that offends a lot of people but
I'm sorry
specially electricians who believe
they're dealing with something and they
failed to identify that something simply
because they can't see or touch it
that's the only reason really okay
another comment here and this fellow
said when monochromatic laser light goes
through a glass or prism does it change
color and the answer is no and here I've
got a little picture to show that okay
give me a second I'll put it up here
okay you can see that monochromatic
light going through a prism does break
up but it does
break up in colors okay it doesn't break
up in colors because it's made of a
single frequency or wavelength and so if
anything you changes a little bit of
color when it comes out or when it goes
I'm sorry when it goes through the
through the prism but it doesn't break
up into colors like white light does and
then we had another comment here let me
get this one out of the way and says if
you go to Fermilab's video they
explicitly state at some ten Lana when
one wave is moving at a different speed
than the other one bill this has nothing
to do with amplitude you lied well see
the problem is the guy said speed he
said speed it came out of his mouth but
that's not what he showed yeah so so
again he just said it he's the guy who
lied not me this is what he showed okay
and this is a standard in anyone who
knows anything about amplitude okay
this is what he showed something like
this and you can see that the speed here
is is the same for both waves and you
might say what was that true well let me
show it to you if I can get it up here
okay there it is you can see that if you
look at those that edge there you can
see that the two waves are moving at the
same speed there is no difference in
speed what you have is just difference
in wave amplitude that's all you have so
the guy showed wave amplitude and said
speed and this guy bought it simply
because the guy said speed and he wasn't
looking at what the guy was presenting
what the guy was presenting in at the
Fermilab and I showed that in a previous
you know two videos ago was wave
amplitude that's what he talked about
and wave amplitude has nothing to do
with speed in fact if you look at the
equation C equals frequency times
wavelength where do you see amplitude
in that equation nowhere so amplitude is
what he showed but amplitude has nothing
to do with speed but speed is what this
guy said and what he showed was
amplitude so again no you're wrong
you're wrong you're the one who's lying
or you're being fooled by this fellow
from Fermilab who makes lots of money
and doesn't know the basics doesn't know
the fundamentals of what he's talking
about anyways with that I'm gonna
continue Wednesday and we'll see you
then
bye bye